[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
primero sin empleo y luego sin hogar esa
es la realidad de miles de migrantes y
refugiados en el mundo afectados por la
pandemia del cob y 19 ante esto muchas
familias han tenido que vivir en la
calle y solo la ayuda de algunos
ciudadanos y organizaciones humanitarias
les ha permitido sortear la situación
los testimonios son similares en
diferentes países en los últimos días en
parís al menos 300 personas sin techo se
reunieron en la plaza de la república
para llamar la atención del gobierno
sobre su situación de vulnerabilidad
entre ese número muchos son extranjeros
una familia marfileña consiguió refugio
por una noche gracias a un anfitrión
solidario la historia a continuación
llueve al caer la noche en parís
y este grupo de personas no tiene donde
pasar la noche
acampan frente al ayuntamiento con la
esperanza de que hoy logren descansar
bajo techo fatuh y su familia
procedentes de costa de marfil lo harán
hoy una joven decidió brindar su casa
para dar abrigo a los que no tienen
hogar durante una noche ante la falta de
ayuda gubernamental todas las personas
que los acogen en sus hogares son
ciudadanos voluntarios que no reciben
dinero por eso no queremos ocupar el
lugar del estado estamos aquí porque no
tenemos otra opción
para llegar a la casa de su anfitriona
deben cruzar la ciudad están cansados y
esta situación les genera una profunda
incertidumbre
james andaluz ya me siento mal de hecho
todos los días lloró hoy lloré con uno
de los agentes lloré y le dije yo no
pensé que iba a pasar por esto pero
desafortunadamente esta es mi vida hoy
entonces qué voy a hacer yo
[Música]
y sabe les abre las puertas de su casa y
los acomoda en una habitación para fatou
su vida en francia no era lo que
esperaban
con una vida como ésta cómo no voy a
arrepentirme pero si les digo a mis
padres en casa que duerma fuera no lo
creerán sin embargo esta es la realidad
una triste realidad para miguelito
y saber les brinda a su casa por uno o
más días pero la mayoría de los que
acoge se quedan sólo una noche y
comparten con ella el día siguiente
cuando vi la forma en que vivía la gente
cuando los acompañe a quedarse en carpas
fue cuando realmente dije que había una
gran falta de alojamiento y que el
estado no estaba tomando sus
responsabilidades de pasión a su
solicitud como isabel son siento los
franceses que abren sus casas cada noche
para recibir a personas sin hogar desde
2018 no es ilegal hacerlo antes se
pagaban hasta cinco años de prisión por
acoger a personas en situación irregular
de vuelta a las calles parisinas este es
un panorama unos 300 migrantes y
refugiados que llegaron de áfrica o
afganistán ocuparon el gimnasio del
distrito 11 apoyados por organizaciones
de ayuda para exigir al gobierno que se
les brinde cobijo 2 hacer afuera
he estado durmiendo allí durante cuatro
meses no hay lugar no hay comida no hay
donde ducharse no hay dinero no hay
lugar no hay nada
los activistas dicen que no cuentan con
los recursos para atender a esta
cantidad de personas que buscan ayuda
la plaza de la republica también fue un
lugar de concentración una medida de
presión que parece dar resultados
después de reunirse aquí pacíficamente
lograron que las autoridades los
trasladarán hasta lugares de alojamiento
temporales pero la crisis de los
sintecho va más allá de solucionar su
estadía por una noche
en nueva york que la situación no es
diferente un grupo de emigrantes latinos
vive en las calles de queens en carpas
después de perder sus trabajos por la
pandemia ser indocumentados no les
permite acceder a las ayudas
gubernamentales
debajo de un puente de las vías del tren
vive un grupo de hispanos que quedaron
sin hogar por la pandemia migraron hace
varios años y hasta hace poco se las
habían arreglado para sobrevivir sin
documentos en estados unidos pero la
crisis golpeó sus lugares de trabajo eso
no me ha pasado
nunca me ha pasado
yo siempre tenía dinero gracias adiós
nunca digo nada siempre me estaba
ayudando
me quede así poco a poco quedaron sin
recursos para pagar un alquiler y
terminaron en la calle viviendo en
carpas y con pocas de sus pertenencias
y después ya no podía pagar renta
podíamos salir por
sotero completa tres meses viviendo aquí
antes trabajaba en dos restaurantes de
manhattan y ganaba 800 dólares
ahora recoge botellas y latas para
reciclar
15 eran trabajadores de la construcción
y el resto eran repartidores o
trabajaban en la hostelería estaban
lavando platos o eran cocineros su
testimonio es el reflejo de muchos
inmigrantes sin papeles a los que la
pandemia dejó en la calle según el
migration policy institute las cifras
del desempleo entre los inmigrantes
hispanos se duplicaron en un año y
pasaron de 4.8 por ciento en enero de
2020 a 8,8 en febrero de 2021
en américa latina' un estudio realizado
por agencias de la onu y la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos
reveló que cerca del 40% de los
migrantes y refugiados venezolanos
fueron desalojados durante la pandemia
además un 38 por ciento está en riesgo
de perder su hogar en el país de acogida
hasta aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]